drôle de nuit qui est atteint mais wayne
gilles bettmer à sens contraire de la
voix
vous l'avez assurément reconnu daniel
boucher et vous savez qu'en raison de la
pandémie l'annulation des concerts et
des festivals des artistes ont dû
s'adapter une nouvelle réalité en misant
notamment sur des spectacles sont
virtuels si c'est loin d'être une
recette miracle certains parviennent
tout de même à tirer leur épingle du jeu
et c'est le cas d'ailleurs donc avec ces
images qu'on vous a montré dès le départ
de daniel boucher auteur compositeur
interprète québécois qu'on rejoint je
crois à mont louis en gaspésie monsieur
boucher un oui qui votera pas et je vois
en arrière également aussi on est
directement à votre studio
il ya même une affiche de gilles
vigneault il ya un autre également aussi
de robert charlebois vous disiez les
délais légaux sont jamais loin
je mets l'eau n'ont jamais loi également
aussi dans votre musique
on le dit évidemment donc les spectacles
dans les salles ça fait plusieurs
bauxite arrêté et là où vous avez décidé
de faire des concerts sur la plateforme
zoom de façon tout à fait indépendante
falls et les gens achètent des billets
et franchement ça a été tout un succès
mais ç'a bien été en fait on espérait
que les gens répondent mais j'avoue
qu'ils ont répondu plus compensés et
j'ai pas essayé d'expliquer pourquoi ça
s'est passé comme ça mais je dirais
peut-être que le fait qu on est en
partant conte et demi qu'on ait mis les
choses au clair les gens heureux
ça va être simple ça va être clair
l'émotion va passer et ça va ça va être
des performances axe histoire d'amuser
sur l'atome
donc on va fasse passer la toune et des
genres je pense une impression aussi de
participer à la création quelque chose
de nouveau c'est parce que c'est un peu
ça qu'on est en train de faire je pars
tout juste de nous autres parce que il
ya beaucoup de gens le qui travaille
avec le virtuel depuis le début de la
pandémie et c'est une bonne chose selon
moi mais
le fait qu'on participe tous ensemble la
seule les spectateurs aussi
on a l'impression qu'on est en train de
taper une treille là on est en train
d'ouvrir le nouvelle branche de notre
métier est quelque chose de nouveau et
effectivement c'est un grand succès vous
avez vendu combien de billets me daniel
boucher mais au total si on compte le
nombre d'entrées totale parce que ce
n'est pas juste des billets unitaires
l'occident notre formule il y avait des
forfaits city ça a été aussi une bonne
idée
j'avoue qu'on a eu cette bonne idée là
écoute ça fait pas loin de quatre mille
entrées 4 ouais donc déjà des gens qui
avaient c'est que je pensais 15 à
l'heure donc par spectacle de grosso
modo mais on peut pas calculer sont
comme ça comme je dis c'est parce qu'il
ya des forfaits hockey en même temps
c'est on aurait on aurait aimé en
vendent bien aimé l'entrée à l'essai su
alors vraiment donc un succès et on
parle de spectacles de combien une heure
plus plus d'une heure ouais ouais ouais
ouais non non non dans matin il fallait
pas que ça dépend 60 minutes j'ai pris
cela parce que ma premièrement comme j
ai dit c'est quelque chose qu'on connaît
pas encore beaucoup fait que on a essayé
de trouver le juste milieu entre une
prestation assez longue pour que les
gens en sortent
commente un mais en même temps faut
toujours passion et petit peu trop court
il faut toujours que faut toujours qu'on
ait le goût devant le prochain et et on
a travaillé là dessus puis je pense
qu'on est tombé pas loin de la cible
parce que ça a bien répondu tu sais au
point où on a le goût de continuer il
fait un combo gargan ghana au sénégal
boucher parce qu'il ait pas de frais de
sable peu de couples sont associés mais
quand même ça prend une bonne connexion
sont pas de bonnes connexions internet
et là vous avez parlé de fret salle et
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets
et c'est important je content que vous
en parliez parce que ce qu'on a fait et
puis c'est vraiment important pour moi
parce que la pandémie c'est quelque
chose de temporaire
on espère que cet apport et on va finir
par retourner dans les salles et c'est
important que les diffuseurs comprennent
aussi que on va continuer à les jouer
dans les salles
ces mots j'ai hâte de retourner d'un
saint just de retourner au festival
alors de le faire mais en même temps je
pense que ce qu'on est en train de
mettre sur pied la va pouvoir continuer
une fois que la pandémie devrait être
terminée parce que justement on fait des
choses qu'on ne peut pas voir
on vit des moments qu'on ne peut pas
vivre dans une salle on parle vraiment
de deux expériences qui sont absolument
différentes et complémentaires
complémentaires et vous moins évidemment
que vous avez une bonne notoriété les
gens vous connaissent des messes
castrais modèle qui serait plus
difficile à essayer pour des artistes
émergents par exemple ça dépend comment
on voit ça parce que les modèles de
diffusion traditionnels sont pas
évidents pour les artistes émergents non
plus et la raison est simple c'est parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'artistes émergents
j'ai beaucoup de bons artistes émergents
et les diffuseurs font ce qu'ils peuvent
pour en diffuser plus possible aussi
donc ça peut être une façon alternative
de rejoindre des gens ici et ailleurs ça
il ya aussi le fait que ben quand je
suis vous et puis que tu es tu assistes
un show bientôt pas besoin de te
déplacer il y en a qui sont contents de
ce cd show de chez eux
moi j'ai vu toutes sortes d'affaires
somme j'ai vu des barbecues
j'ai vu des gens qui avaient installé
des lumières dans leur salon il y en a
qui dansaient y en a qui avait des
pancartes et cox était c'était vraiment
particulier et est donc ça peut être
quand je disais juste une expérience
différente ce que je veux dire et on
part on tire on parle même pas des gens
qui ne peuvent pas se déplacer
il ya des gens pour qui c'est compliqué
de les voir un show dans un châle donc
je pense vraiment qu'on est en train
d'ouvrir une nouvelle branche de notre
métier son travail bien payé mais qu'un
membre
ça devrait ça devrait être capable on
devrait capable de faire des juristes
fait en vingt secondes de la bouche est
ce que vous trouvez que le gouvernement
à être suffisamment le milieu culturel
actuellement je pense à très honnêtement
je pense que nathalie roy fait vraiment
du mieux qu'elle peut faire ok et je
pense que
entendu j'espère qu'elle entendu les
artistes autoproducteurs les pigistes
tout ça parce que c'était les grandes
oubliées
hélas l ajuster certains programmes
j'espère que c'est suffisant évidemment
pas que le temps va nous le dire mais
généralement je suis assez content de
l'équipe de nathalie roux jusqu'à
présent oui mais aussi beaucoup ça te
plaisait merci nous avons écrit dans
notre studio daniel boucher et broker
salue bientôt merci au revoir à passer